[موسيقى]
كيف قادر اقلب الافكار البراسي لحقيقه كيف
قادر اوصل للاحلام اللي بتمح له ومره
تانيه ليه مو انا اللي
تحدثنا اليوم
وصلت طموحات كبيره من خلال نجاحاته قدر
ينشر اجزاء من سوريا للعالم الخارجي نفس
الوقت جذب انتباه العالم العربي والغربي
بان واحد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
رحبوا معي الشاب المهندس مؤسس منصه
ميسيريا ايمن محمد رفاعي
مساء الخير انا ايمن محمد الرفاعي عمري 25
سنه خبروني انه انا اليوم اصغر سبيكر
مشارك معكم الصراحه هذا الموضوع خوفني بس
بنفس الوقت حفزني خلاني افكر شو ممكن اقدم
وقديه ممكن تكونوا مستمتعين معنا بعتقد
هلا عم تسالوا حالكم لا عنوان حديثنا هو
اسمه ليمو انا
لحتى اقدر اجاوبكم لازم نرجع شوي بالوقت
لل 2013 كان عمري بهذاك الوقت 15 سنه
بوقتها مع بدايه انتشار الفيسبوك وسوشيال
ميديا بمنطقتنا قررت انشئ صفحه على
السوشيال ميديا اسمها هنا دمشق بعتقد كثار
منكن ما بيعرف هاي القصه وهي اول مره
بحكيها بهديك الفتره حاولت اقدم صوره عن
الشام انا بشوفها بعيوني
بالرغم من وقتك كانت الامكانيات قليله من
التلفونات اللي كانت معنا او حتى من
المواد المصوره لدمشق على السوشيال ميديا
بس بعتقد بفتره قليله قدرت حقق جزء من
حلمي وقدر اوصل لانتشار معقول جدا بهديك
الفتره بس للاسف ما قدرت تكمل فيها لانه
كان عندي شهاده التاسع بس اكيد حلمي ما
وقف عندها هلا حنرجع على 2017 بهذيك
الفتره كان في موضوعين عم يزعجوني جدا
الموضوع الاول هو اسطوره النمطيه للغرب عن
سوريا يلي هي مربوطه بالصحراء بالخيم وانه
نحن بلدنا حضاري الصوره الثانيه الها
علاقه بالحرب بسوريا للاسف ارتبطت بسوريا
فورا بالدم والخراب حقيقه عن هذا الموضوع
كان زعجني جدا
وكنت اسال حالي ليه ما في منصات على
السوشيال ميديا بهديك الفتره قادره توجه
الصوره الحلوه عن سوريا وهون سالت حالي
السؤال لاول مره ليه مو انا الي قادر اعمل
منصه بتحكي عن سوريا لحتى اقدر ورجي
العالم كيف انا بشوف سوريا بعيوني هون
بخريف 2017 قدرت اعمل منصه على الفيسبوك
وانستغرام اسمها مايداماسكس بوقتها
كان هدفي بسيط اني اقدر بس اوجه العالم
انا كيف بشوف الشام بعيوني حتى كمان
بوقتها الصراحه كانت الامكانيات مالها
كتير قويه ما عندي شيء اقدر اصور فيه غير
موبايلي حتى بهديك الفتره انا وحيد لاهلي
على خمس بنات هذا الشيء خلاني يكون ملتزم
مع اهلي اني اقوم باماكن محدده بدمشق فما
كنت قادر اتفتل كتير بالشام لحتى اقدر
اصورها وتشوفوها بس قدرت وانا وقاعد
بغرفتي وعلى موبايلي اعمل هاي المنصه بعد
سنه بلشت مايدا ماسكه نعرف اكتر بلشت
العالم
تعرفها بلشت توصل لشهره معقوله وهون قررنا
انه نحن نتوسع نروح لحلب نعمل منصه اسمها
مي اليبو
وبلشنا وهدفنا كان بهديك الفتره انه نحن
نعمل المنصات لكل مدينه بسوريا لحتى
العالم كلها تشوف هالمدهن قديش جميله بس
بالالفين خطرت اعضاءنا فكره طيب ليه ما
نعمل منصه وحده بتشمر سوريا كلها هون
بيكون تركيزنا موحد بمكان واحد قادرين
نعمل محتوى بيليق فيها وهون بلشنا بس
بهديك الفتره كلياتنا بنعرف بلشت كورونا
ازمه عالميه العالم كلها خايفه منها خايفه
من شي مجهول قعدت بالحجر ببيوتها داخل
الاعمال هون نحن ما ملينا الصراحه هون
اشتغلنا على محتوى ماي سيريا بلشنا نحط
محتوى خاص فينا افكار جديده نوصل لفئه
كبيره من العالم وحقيقه
الفتره قدرنا نعمل انتشار معقول جدا قدرنا
نوصل لكثير عالم بسوريا وبرا سوريا وهون
كان شيء كتير سعيد بالنسبه لأنه هلا تذكرت
ببداياتي كان في عندي اصدقاء مقربين مني
بتذكر بوقتها كانوا يقولوا لي ايمن شو بدك
بهالقصه اتسلى بموضوع التهاني
شو حتقدر تغير بالعالم انت وقتها بعد لو
كان ايماني وشغفي ضعيف كنت سمعت كلامهم
تركته وما عملت هذا الشيء بس انا اخذت هذا
الكلام بايجابيه اخدته حافز لالي لحتى كل
مره كنت تعبان فيها مضغوط بشيء معين هو
يكون عم يقويني انه في حافز عم يخليني
اعمل شيء لاحلو والصراحه كان حافظ جدا مهم
نفس هدول الاشخاص هنن اليوم اكبر الداعمين
لالي هم اللي بيتشكروني جدا عايشين اللي
عملناه وناطرين منها دائما كل شيء جديد
اليوم الميديا كلياتنا بنعرف قديه هي مهمه
بالعالم وبسوريا كلياتنا بنعرف انه فينا
نحنا نستغلها بشيء ايجابي وبشيء سلبي فهون
سالت حالي للمره الثانيه ليه مو انا اللي
قادر استغل هاي الميديا بشكل ايجابي كرمال
سوريا وهون بلشنا نطوي على سوريا من
الناحيه الجماليه الثقافيه تراثيه بتراسل
الماضي وللماضي تاريخ السياحه وحتى نضوي
على نجاح السوريين من كل العالم لكل
العالم والحمد لله عم نحاول قد ما فينا
نقدر نعمل هذا الشيء
وهون بصراحه بعد هاي الفتره كلياتها
صار في عنا مسؤوليه كتير كبيره اليوم
مايسيريا قدرت توصل لعدد كثير كبير من
العالم ملايين او حتى عشرات الملايين من
المتابعين على السوشيال ميديا فهذا الشيء
اعطاني مسؤوليه بشكل خاص اني انا اكون
كتير مؤكد من اي معلومه ممكن تنشر عنها من
اي محتوى ممكن ينزل وبعتقد هاي المسؤوليه
تخططني انا كفرت هي صارت مسؤوليه كل
السوريين انه نحن عن جد نقدر نقدم محتوى
يليق باسم سوريا محتوى بنقدر نحن نفتخر
فيه باي مكان بالعالم والحمد لله نحن
اليوم قدرنا نوصل لاكثر من 75 دوله حول
العالم هي بتحب سوريا عم تتابع سوريا وعم
تعرف اخبارها من خلالها
هلا بقول شو في احلى من انه الانسان يربط
شغفه بدراسته وهون كمان سالت حالي السؤال
للمره الثالثه ليه مو انا اللي قادر اربط
شغفي بدراستي هون ربطت شغفي بالاستكشاف
والتوثيق بدراستي للهندسه المعماريه قبل
شهرين تماما كنت واقف نفس هاي الوقفه على
قاعده جامعتي عم اقدم مشروع تخرجي بوقتها
عملت تحدي لنفسي باني ادم مشروع مربوط
بذاكرتنا بدمشق وسوريا مشروعي كان بعنوان
اعاده تاهيل محور سوق الصالحيه وحديقه
عروس هون اخذت عهد على نفسي بانه
بالمستقبل انا اخد مشاريع لها علاقه بعاده
التاهيل تطوير وتجميل المناطق اللي بتهمنا
بدمشقيين وكسوريين وبتمنى من كل المهندسين
ياخذوا بهي الخطوه لحتى نقدر نقدم
بتصور بسيط بيليق باسم سوريا حضاره
وبالسوريين
وكمان
شو في احلى من انه نحن عن جد نقدر نقدم
هذا المحتوى بهدف سامي ونبيل اللي هو
سوريا بتمنى هاي عن جد المهمه المهمه ما
تكون مهمتنا كافراد
لوحدنا انه هي تكون مهمه جماعيه لنقدر
كلياتنا نقدر نقدم هذه الصوره بالختام
حابب لكم
وثقوا بحلمكم حقوها ما تردوا على حدا انا
لو رديت من خمس سنين على كلام رفقاتي انا
ما كنت متواجد معكم اليوم كاصغر سبيكر ما
كنت اكون حققت جزء مهم من احلامي وانا
متاكد بعد فتره قليله حادر احلامي اكثر
فبتمنى انه كلياتنا نقدر احلام هلا في
فيديو حنشوفه كان اهداء مني لمدينه دمشق
بمناسبه مشروع تخرجي حنشوف سوا ونرجع
[تصفيق]
الى دمشق اقدم ايقونه ماهوله في قلبي
المدينه التي ولدتني وعشت بها على قدره
اعطتني الكثير واعطيتها ما استطعت بتواضع
زهريه نبتت في حديقتيار رغبه منها في ان
تزيد من جماله
[تصفيق]
قبل ما ودعتهم بدي اقول لكم على مبدا انا
ماشي فيه الصراحه
كل سوري هو سفير بلده بالمكان اللي هو
متواجد فيه عايش فيه وبشتغل فيه شو في
احلى من اليوم نكون نحن عن جد خير سفراء
لسوريا بدي اشكر فريق مايلي هنن عن جد
اعظم سفراء انا تعرفت عليهم بسوريا وبكثير
من دول العالم بدي اشكركم كلكم وشكرا
[تصفيق]